the Joe Rogan experience I met this
amazing guy last night who we were
talking about he grew up in Egypt
hussein abu bakr's his name he's really
incredible grew up in Egypt and was you
know he was like I was swimming in
anti-semitism I just didn't even know it
wasn't normal
like the mosque I went to the school I
went to it was like the Jews were this
super villain and the whole message was
like become a super hero and go and kill
and defeat the Jews and he was like I
went to a normal most normal school this
is what I was taught and I never met a
Jew in my life and he gets arrested
during the Arab Spring because he starts
learning Hebrew online he's really
curious about who the Jews are and he
gets arrested I think they're suspicious
that he's a Zionist spy anyway he ends
up getting asylum he lives here in LA he
got arrested for learning Hebrew oh whoa
oh yeah you think I can like just go
visit Egypt I mean no these are so if
you wanted to visit the pyramids you'd
be [ __ ] I don't know well how I would
specifically be [ __ ] because I have
like a public profile as a Jew right um
you don't want to go looking online for
my name in some of these forums it's
like really scary but do you look at it
no no there are people who look at it
for me and tell me what I need to like
be aware of and you know like every sin
of every synagogue I speak to it's like
people don't realize that I went to a
synagogue Friday night in LA
like there's armed guards at every
synagogue and Jewish function that I go
to now it's like going through TSA to go
to like imagine that if most Americans
had to do that when they went into
church like we think that's insane but
that is the state of affairs for Jews
and Jews that I know hide evidence of
their identity everywhere they go I
there was a woman who wrote me who was
reading my book on the subway in New
York and was like I'm nervous to be seen
reading a book with this title in public
and like hit it but I understand why
because it's it's become so regular and
everyone else just isn't living their
normal life and we're like sounding the
alarm here because if there's one thing
the Jews have gotten really good at it's
like we have an instinct for danger like
that is something that we have
cultivated over years of being
discriminated against persecuted against
nearly wiped off the map in Europe like
we understand and we smell danger
sometimes but for other people do you
think that anti-semitism is more
prominent on the East Coast and the west
coast I think that's a good question
there are just more Jews on the East
Coast there's a lot of Jews out here
there are yeah there are I don't know I
don't live out here so I'm not sure I
also think it's different right like
there are different kinds of
anti-semitism
like the kind that we've talked about
that comes on the far-right expresses
itself one way and there's also
anti-semitism that comes smuggled into
the mainstream through the political
left that comes cloaked in language that
is very seductive like the language of
social justice and progress and if the
right claims that the Jews are you know
fake white people the far left claims
that the Jews are handmaidens to white
supremacy so whiteness plays like a
really really key role in the way that
anti-semitism functions right and here
let me explain it this way anti-semitism
is a shape-shifting conspiracy theory
except that right and that is how under
Nazism Jews are the race contaminate
errs how under communism we are the arch
capitalists right how under the idea of
white supremacy we are these fake white
people right we appear to be white
people but we're actually doing the
bidding of these groups who white
supremacists view to be lesser than
black people brown people Muslims
immigrants and how on the far left the
Jews are seen as sort of the great what
is the greatest evil right now to the
far left whiteness and white privilege
and Jews are seen as sort of handmaiden
to that why because of our success
because many of us are of Eastern
European descent 85% of American Jews
are of Ashkenazi which is of Eastern
European descent so we pass as white so
we have white privilege and so in the
intersectional view of the world right
which reverses the caste system that
we've been living in until now where you
have someone like Jon Hamm at the very
top and black transgender disabled
people at the very
well the intersectional worldview comes
around and reverses that and says no
John Hammond cisgendered white men like
Joe Rogan are now at the very bottom and
at the very top are the transgender
black disabled person and so where are
the Jews in that new intersectional
caste system of the world we're kind of
like right above Jon Hamm we're right
near him because we have we enjoy all of
the sort of privileges that he enjoys
it's a crazy thing but that's sort of
where we are in the handmaidens to white
privilege or white supremacy is very
strange that's a very strange one and
the anti-israeli sentiment yes yeah no I
understand what you're saying
and well I see it with people where they
openly expressed disdain for Jewish
people I've seen it from a lot of people
that you would call activists you know
of varying religious identity you mean
left-wing activist yes yeah yeah it's
like I think of it very crudely if a
racism is the sin that's sort of
acceptable on the far right hating Jews
is the sin that's acceptable on the far
left the far left because of support for
Israel they believe that Israel is
dominating Palestine and that Hezbollah
is misunderstood and then there's
there's all these different sentiments
that get expressed openly in these left
circles mm-hmm that's right and they're
telling you no they're basically
propagating they're repeating without
even realizing it this Soviet propaganda
line which is the design ISM is racism
which is an unbelievable thing to say
because the majority of Jews who live in
Israel are Jews of North African and
Middle Eastern descent they are
non-white people they are Arabs they are
Arab Jews and yet you have the far left
basically exporting parochial domestic
American racial politics on to a foreign
conflict and place that they know
absolutely nothing about you know these
people are delusional they think that
like all of the conflict in the Middle
East would be resolved if only we took
care of this one tiny conflict between
this tiny group of people and their
neighbors were in fact it's like a
tiny local conflict in this huge drama
of the Middle East of which there are a
zillion players and you know the Jews of
Israel are only one tiny part of it
[Applause]